Speaker 1: OK. Lastly, there is now a very
strange situation in the state of Georgia,
and as a result, Donald Trump has put out a
bizarrely lit, sweaty endorsement. VIDEO Where
the background is bright, Trump is
dark and glistening and looks confused
and actually opens the statement by saying, Hello,
I'm President Donald Trump. I guess he thinks
his name recognition has declined and some people
might not know who he is. This is this is what
I understand what this video is up until a few
days ago. Vernon Jones was running against David
Perdue for governor of Georgia. So remember, David
Perdue was a senator from Georgia. He ultimately
lost to Jon Ossoff in that special election on
January 5th of 2021. And then David Perdue said,
I'm going to run for governor. Vernon Jones,
also running for governor against David Perdue,
drops out a couple of days ago and says, I'm
actually going to run for representative for the
House of Representatives. It's not because he's
a great supporter of David Perdue. It's because
he realized he has a much better shot of winning
in the House of Representatives than he does at
defeating David Perdue for the governorship. So
the timing is all bizarre. And Trump says, Well,
this guy's a big supporter of Perdue. Not really.
He was actually running against him. And every
aspect of this is just strange. The lighting is
weird. The delivery is weird. It has a sort of
hostage video feel. Let's take a look at that.
Speaker 5: Hello, I'm President Donald Trump.
And when it comes to Georgia's 10th Congressional
District, right, I have only one choice,
and the man's name is Vernon Jones, a very special
person. He's an America First fighter who will
never back down to either the establishment or
the radical left. Few fought harder for election
integrity in 2020 than Vernon, and he's a big
supporter of a very good man running for Governor
David Perdue. He has my complete and total
endorsement. Vernon will not let you down.
Let's send a true patriot to Congress.
Speaker 1: OK, so there is Donald Trump,
and the lighting is reminiscent of what director
of photography Gordon Willis developed for The
Godfather. Just all very, very strange.
And I just cannot get a straight answer
about the timing of any of this.
It's all extraordinarily strange,
and I'm. And by the way, the other thing is we're
going to see the power of the Trump endorsement.
We're really going to see the power of
the Trump endorsement at this point.
Donald Trump claims to have just a fantastic
record as far as endorsements go, and we're
actually going to review that record tomorrow.
In reality, the record is not really that great.
It's very average, and it will be interesting to
see what that endorsement record ends up being
in November of 2022. That's going
to be a big factor in determining
whether Trump even runs or has a shot in 2024. Do
the Trumpian and Trump endorsed individuals win
in the November midterms, or do they lose?
And we'll be watching those results very, very
closely. We have a fantastic bonus show today.
Remember the bonus show attacked by Alex Jones?
Speaker 5: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad crazy.
Speaker 1: On today's bonus show by many economic
indicators, the economy is strong, but voters are
not feeling that it is strong. And that is another
problem for Joe Biden. We're going to talk about
that on the bonus show. California is suing Tesla
over allegations of discrimination and
harassment. We're going to talk about it
and Al Franken. Remember Al Franken, Senator
Democratic senator from Minnesota? He says it,
you know, it would be tempting to run for office
again. We're going to talk about the legacy of Al
Franken and the circumstances of him ultimately
leaving office. All of those stories and more on
today's bonus show. Get instant access by signing
up at Join Pacman Dot. We will see you that.